we begin with a story that sounds like a
movie but it's not this is all true the
drama surrounding an FBI raid on
president Trump's private lawyer and
fixer now includes one of the
president's biggest supporters in the
media Fox News host Sean Hannity is
defending his ties to attorney Michael
Cohen after a judge forced Cohen to
reveal in court that Hannity is a client
that hearing yesterday featured another
spectacle when an adult film star stormy
Daniels showed up Michael Cohen faces a
criminal investigation of his personal
business dealings and possible campaign
finance violations he's fighting to
control evidence taken by the FBI Jeff
Pegues is here with the revelation that
turned heads in the courtroom Jeff good
morning good morning it was quite the
bombshell in the courtroom when that
federal judge forced Michael Cohen's
lawyers to disclose Hannity's name after
they tried to keep it a secret
arguing that Cohen believed it would be
embarrassing for hannity if his name
became public Michael Cole never
represented me in any legal matter
he continued deny being Cohen's client I
did have occasional brief conversations
with Michael Kohn they never involved
any matter any sorry to dissapoint so
many matter between me or third party a
third groups at all Anna T once
described Cohen is a good friend came to
his defense after the FBI raided Cohen's
home office and hotel room last one the
media is spinning out of control
following the FBI's reign Cohen has been
a guest on Sean Hannity show with both
men frequently coming to the president's
defense the media and the left want to
destroy Donald Trump their goal is to
malign a very good man for months Cohen
has been under criminal investigation
for his personal business dealings judge
Kimball would ordered prosecutors to
enter but not review the material seized
from Cohen's properties on to a
searchable database and then share it
with the defense Woods will then decide
whether the grant Cohen's request to
appoint a special master to review the
documents in order to decide what may be
protected by attorney-client privilege
federal investigators are looking into
whether Cohen violated campaign finance
laws when he paid stormy Daniels a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
keep silent about her alleged sexual
encounter with President Trump in 2006
Daniels attended Monday's hearing but
had no role the adult film star created
a media frenzy with her appearance at
the courthouse for years mr. Cohen has
acted like he is above the law
Daniel's attorney Michael avenatti
anyone that had any contact with this
man in the last twenty years should be
very concerned about what secrets of
theirs are within these documents the
exact nature of Cohen's work for hannity
is unclear but on a show last night the
Fox News host insisted that it was
mostly for real-estate advice also the
judge denied the president's request a
review materials seized in those raids
mr. Trump's lawyers insisting that his
attorney-client privilege is in jeopardy
the White House is not yet responded to
a request for comment Gail
all right Jeff for real estate vice and
last I checked Michael Cohen is not a
real estate lawyer that's interesting
too